yeah welcome to this video let's get
going here 1d for ok rump this ur romp
in the center ok sweden sweden that is
ok the banco or some benoni how the
chick benoni this very close to type of
baloney yeah i usually play it with g3
ok yeah one point of this is that what
very often has f4 available so castles
Bishop g5 is now answered with f form
okay um pusher page six I guess and
Queen to d2 that looks quite normal I
wondered yeah he might have king age 89
g idea sending sad day I'm sorry sending
my bishop bag but I came it's not a not
a huge deal after f5 I go f4 that's the
the big idea one big idea of the setup
um his six I can't play a three before
it's not not a bad idea it's kind of
curious so before he allows me to play
that it takes takes rook c8 but I have
c5 takes d6 this kind of thing
c5 attacks textbook CH c 5 t x d6c
before texas am now that's good for
murder yeah so i think i can I can do
that I mean he probably will just play
b6 and then keep it closed but I think
I'm opening the be foul should be
something that is helpful for me
yeah okay let's not spend much time here
um so look be one I guess when at five
are so go F for TR the bee farm I can
put it a rock on b7 but it's not doing
really a lot okay so f 5 + f4 is the
standard answer and yeah that was this
was pretty much clear yeah but if i take
i can take you five the sugar form
trading trading this I'm sure about it
but okay it should be it should be fine
for white I'm not not saying I'm usually
better or anything but getting this
traded should be useful for me d six
this is week so he cannot just put it
back on f6 on something we will
definitely trade this trade this bishop
now I can always hope for this little
bit of space that I have and the beef
i'll create that I really did not think
about much maybe it would be 6 i'm
getting getting on this d 6 pod I'm
threatening a look t6 now this is a
threat this exchange sacrifice and up to
60 it's not reacting ok he is reacting
I'm sorry rook d6 he can play a night
except for meeeeee yeah if I take and
Queen takes its that's kind of annoying
really but but I can just let's take
your first I need to have a terribly
loud sound here this check sounds and so
on and all night f4 was my idea yeah ok
let's do it threatens night takes h5 and
takes pawn takes should be quite nice
for me
you still has this issue is here with
the with the Queen having to protect t6
all the time and I'm not I am almost
threatening 96 is this now I move 96 was
probably not but I have this cheeky
amity can always just retreat ok I'm
going to going to take him seeking with
the bishop looks shaky after rookie one
but he's got queen deform only that one
square it is it is available and wow
that move I didn't think about it all so
I can go here you go squinty for ok no
isn't this isn't this a nice position I
mean 24 I'm going to take two nitee to
where I guess just trying to to snatch
the pawn rook e8 I go look d 1 and d 6
is still hanging so now that's pretty
good for wide but as usual I have a bit
down on time I tried to play plated I
tried to play quickly but it didn't work
out to perfection ok I had to unpin of
course and now I'm threatening on deform
for real
and d6 hangs very important yes now I'm
just a very little time behind on the
clock and still d6 seems very weak
yeah night is just beautiful on a form
still d 6 & a 6 Hanks so he has to go
for some kind of counter play this loop
g8 account I am even if he takes on g3
it's not it's not that terrible really
now that's a cell time Marcy 5 and don't
see the point I am a probably it was
probably lost any way too many
weaknesses really d 6 and so on ok so he
wants to take here it's probably easiest
to do this and then rookie aid to trade
rook check
d 7 yeah i can go d 7 route 28 Bishop
here yeah that's okay 496 check that
it's Northwest check back resins yeah
mmm let's have a quick recap of this
game this is a pretty good setup against
the the Czech benoni or old benoni it
has one very important point it is that
after the move like this which is pretty
pretty common this idea then f form is
an interesting way to play getting space
and asking black if Bishop g5 really was
such a brilliant idea wyd in general
always has this big space advantage the
g6 yeah this is the other idea that
black can go for this is a fairly normal
way to play and then then Anthony then
he went a 6 yeah this is something that
I'm not really sure about normally black
plays f5 nevertheless I mean f4 it's
clear and then something like this and
yeah I definitely prefer white but it is
the way em they often play it as black
it's some very tense situation with this
kind of square of pawns but very often
the problem is that any capture that
black does and this is answered by
something that is quite annoying or
taking on a form so also not a very very
nice prospect with the night putting
pressure here it's very difficult for
black tooth to release the tension
okay went a six and I thought why not go
for before as well so I went for this
here be six young I was thinking about
this idea if this is a possibility
trying to play against my week porn but
I have this idea this was what I
calculated during the game this looks
nice yeah I have this big dicks this big
space and if he takes like g6 this is
this is really not not good yeah
allowing white those pawns I didn't
really see that you can do this move
however it still should be good for
white but I mean something like this
yeah that's not a really nice position
room White has a huge lead in in space
and everything yeah okay we went for
this and now for Bishop f6 and now this
is physically I need to trade this
strong piece yeah interesting around
with this the idea now is rook t6 so if
you place Irena know something like that
I'm take here and I'm just winning area
this kind of thing is is a disaster or
maybe here in this situation I can even
take because it's a temple and so this
is was a good move i guess takes takes
and here i came yeah computer gives 93
this is something that i briefly thought
of it during the game but well I wasn't
sure how bad it is but now that's very
very inconvenient really Aspen
hmm yeah I need to do something like
that but I mean he can take here at
least this is what he should have done
and here I think everything is fine
again yeah this is a mistake and this is
what I already suspected during the game
Bishop cheeks and now now this is I mean
I was thinking rookie one still but
after Queen D for this is much better
than the game if we compare this here it
was really a case where he's full of
weaknesses yeah especially this is
terrible it gives me this eternal square
on f4 and he's got no counter play and
the bishop on f5 would have been so much
better yeah here this is basically
basically winning four wide yeah this is
also confirmed by the engine gives y
plus 3 and so on ya ta can can resign
yeah the crucial point there were two
crucial points he could have taken on g3
I mean which I kind of saw but but
really really two later when I went here
I was thinking can he take maybe and
then he played Knight to f6 em TI he has
to take with the bishop now this also
should be somewhat better for white but
it's not a clear clear thing Queenie 1y
can ok i can look here maybe he has to
go to the far right and if i do the same
thing just the same thing maybe I can
take here first and my Teague's no Night
Moves threatening threatening this and
threatening on d6 and it's also a bit
better for white tricky okay i hope you
liked it thanks for watching